Hi, my name is Rick from Agentuity and
today I'm going to talk to you about
agent native companies or AI native
companies. What that means you hear a
lot of that right now. What does it mean
and uh what are some of the core
attributes and things like that? So, so
imagine if you will, you walk into the
office, past your co-workers, smile away
with them, you sit at your desk, you sit
down, and you check not your email, but
the status of what all your agent
co-workers did over the the night
before, did last night. Uh, they're
pulling you into things that need your
attention, things that they got done or
things that they think need approval.
Um, and so instantly you get brought
into their world on, hey, I need to go
do and execute these things because it's
part of my job. So for a lot of us, I
don't think it's actually hard to
imagine, especially for us that are
doing a lot of these AI things right
now. Uh, certainly at our startup at
Agentuity, uh, we're feeling exactly
that during a team meeting, it's really
common to hear things like, well, just
have Devon go do that. Oh, that's a good
point. We need to go update that. I went
ahead and pinged Devon. and then by the
time we're done with the standup, I've
already got a pull request that we have
to review. Or things like, hey, we
should tweak this channel, um, let's go
ping the content marketing agent and
it'll it'll adjust it. That kind of
thing. So, um, those things are are
common more and more and more,
especially in Agentuity. And we think
that for an agent native or an AI native
company, some of those things are just
going to be the norm. I mean even as
example I was on X recently and a
startup posted a job opening for an
agent manager that's a manager that
manages AI workers pretty interesting
right so we're entering a world where
managing agents can be someone's
full-time job
literally so in this talk I want to
explore that world agent native AI
native companies where AI just isn't an
add-on or just some just some task that
somebody uses but central to how work
gets done. So, we're going to walk
through a few things. We're going to
walk through AI enhanced versus agent
natives. There's a difference or AI
natives. Um what makes a company agentic
um the typical agentic workday and uh
even just like rethink hiring like maybe
we need to think about hiring a little
different. So, that's what we're going
to cover in this presentation. So, let's
just jump right into it. First thing is
AI enhanced versus AI native or agent
native. So what does that mean? Uh
anyway, what is a native company that
uses AI? What does that mean? So
hopefully you're not one of those people
that think that an agent is only a
chatbot. If you are, then you're
probably thinking, well, why would you
what does a chat native company mean? So
if you are one of those, then we
probably need to make another video um
to talk through that. My my intent is
not to talk and convince you what an
agent is. Um it's not just a chatbot,
but in a nutshell, what we mean when we
say agent native um company is a company
built from the ground up with AI agents
at the core of everything to augment
human productivity and intelligence. Um,
I'd also additionally add that um, these
companies build AI into the foundation
of their product, into the foundation of
their operations, and into the
foundation of their culture. Another way
to look at it is AI is not a fancy side
feature that's just a bolt-on um, to
existing operation and culture. It's an
engine that moves the product operation
to culture. It's the thing that moves it
forward. Everybody reaches for that.
everybody relies on it uh to do their
job. So sometimes it's helpful to think
about this in the opposite to contrast.
So for these companies if you
remove agents just for us for our
company agent if you just remove agents
out of our workflow
um and guess what happens our employees
aren't able to get as much done. They're
just
not a lot of the mundane things that we
do unsatisfactory work that we do we
have to now do. And um it it does it's
not as fulfilling. I mean just even for
us we have an agent that uh writes our
change log and our documentation. So
after all this stuff happens in GitHub,
all this code gets written, all these
things get deployed and released. Um we
have to create a change log. We have to
create documentation. We don't do that.
Uh we have an agent do that. And so if
if you were to remove that from us, we
would we'd be very sad. All of us as NG
software engineers would be very sad if
that got removed from us. Um, another
one is if you think about it, removing
AI or agents from a agent native
company,
um, makes us not move as fast. The costs
go up, pro productivity goes down.
Removing AI and agents um, from the
products that we're building. Products
start to feel old, not as interesting,
unintelligent, not as useful. They
certainly don't help the customer 10x
themselves. We're want to 10x or 100x
ourselves. How do we do that with our
customers and our product? Right? Um, so
then all of a sudden now we're not as
good as the competitors. The list goes
on and on and on. But that's the
counterpoint to it. A way to state it is
merely an AI enhanced business. One that
uses AI here and there, chats with it
every once in a while, gets a document
every once in a while. Maybe that helps
with some efficiency goals. It's good.
And they would still function without
AI. That's the key part. If you removed
it from it, it would just they would
still function. It would just not be as
efficient. And that's a car with driver
assist. That's really what we're talking
about. An Asian native business is
different. Isn't the car on autopilot
directed by humans of course, but it's
still autopilot. It's a different kind
of car. Its signature is every employee
is focused on the higher level
navigation task and the success of the
company and the product. While the
routine and mundane tasks, micro
decisions, they get offloaded. That's a
signature part of it. So the thesis that
we have is that an AI native or agent
native model isn't just a tech trend.
It's it's redefining how we build teams,
how we design workflows, even what roles
we hire for. I don't think it's any
different than back in the industrial
revolution and during the car age and
some of those things, how everything got
transformed. I think it's just like
that. So now moving on, uh what makes a
company agent native? Now, obviously,
we're on the early days, very early
days, of course, but here's a few
defining things that make an agent
native company. AI is at the center of
everything. When you say, Rick, yeah,
no, duh. I just listen know it's it's
not confined to just one team or a
feature or one aspect of a company's
culture. It's everywhere and it's
everything. Think of product, think of
customer support, think of ops. In an AI
native company, the expectation is each
of these departments have agents doing
some of the routine and key daily work
all the time. The departments would have
agent interfaces handoff. They integrate
with other departments. I mean this is
obvious, right? In order to be
efficient, you need this. It should be
obvious. But again, think of the
opposite. If you turn that off, each
department, uh, if you turn turn off all
their agents, um, you know, you got a
human scramble trying to coordinate
manually, feeling a loss of productivity
because you had this thing, you had this
way to automate things and to work
faster and to work more, and now you
don't have it anymore. Um, man, that's a
big big big uh loss uh for for us. Like
just thinking about that is painful
right now. We have six people in our
company, seven people, and um, removing
that would be would be bad.
Um, the other thing is with an AI or an
agent native company, people are no
longer just like cogs in a machine.
That's another way to look at it.
They're more like conductors. Now, if
you think about that statement for a
minute, a lot of people make that
statement. It's not a novel statement.
It's a it is an important statement,
though. They're
conductors. You'll realize that the
hiring
profile and the company or chart will
need to be different if that's who
you're hiring. If that's what you need,
flatter leaner is a key attribute. It
starts to become it can be a key
attribute. Middle management layers
shrink because a lot of that
coordination can be handled and executed
by intelligent systems. I mean even in
my own experience, we'll have a deep
dive product discussion in the morning
with the team. By the end of the day, we
have detailed requirements um to work on
something. We already have had agents
start to build it. has already helped us
with the messaging and the copy and some
of the documentation and that's just
within you know a day and so we've had
this culture now of like you well yeah
this is a great idea let's prototype it
and we prototype it in a few hours and
we get some more refinement and agents
help with that a lot help us do more
prototypes and more learning and more
testing that way so that's why we think
at least our org chart in the near
future as we scale is going to look less
like a pyramid and more like a network
of humans and AI
together. Another attribute is
experimentation and iterative culture in
the DNA. So now I know I know I know
know this is a core value in in the tech
startup world. Core value core
innovation is that experimentation
iterative approach to things. So it can
be cliche but if you think about it in
context of an AI native company with all
the innovations we have now the ultimate
realization of this is really possible
when AI is doing the routine work and AI
is helping us with the prototypes we can
really focus on what matters I think
it's I think it's powerful and I think
it's awesome and it also compounds when
you start thinking about agents working
on things in the company learn and
improve it really is useful I Just take
Cognition's dead end. We used it. We
started using it a few months ago. It's
good. We had to do some things and now
over time it's learned so much. It's
documented so much of our code. It knows
how we handle certain things. It's it's
a superpower at this point.
So all of these attributes AI at the
core, humans as orchestrators, uh rapid
experimentation, self-learning, agent
evolution, they combine to create an
organization that looks and feels
totally different from a traditional
company. It's not just a little more
efficient, it's operating in a totally
different model. And so like if you're
an MBA and you're like, I want to I
learned this approach at Berkeley, you
know, and this is here here's my
template. It's not going to fit. It's a
whole other model that we're talking
about. Now, let's talk about the agent
native typical workday. What does that
look like anyway? And I think we have a
lot of ideas on what it can look like in
the future. But really, let's just ask
the question, well, what's new? And
definitely one of the things that's new
is overseeing what AI is doing or what
it has done. That's certainly something
that is um an everyday part of our lives
now that definitely didn't exist just a
few years ago. And so even just me for
example, I usually start my day
uh with a builtup log of things that I
have to get done. And usually I have
certain theme days. I try to put put
certain tasks and certain days. And
sometimes they're mundane tasks.
Sometimes they're product ideas that
need to be thought through. So I found
that like in the morning a lot of times
I'm out for a walk, I'm driving the car
and I'll actually chat which I'll talk
to chat GBT and I use 03 or deep
research um some deep um reasoning stuff
and um just kick off bigger thinking
things like hey this is what we're
thinking of. Here's a document. Here's a
link. This is what we said. Here's a
conversation. Here's a granola
transcript. And then so by the time I
actually get to that to-do for that day,
I've already got a bunch of thinking
around it. it might have kicked off
Devon and created a couple PRs. And
that's definitely the case when there's
uh things like bugs and doc issues and
other things that have amounted from
users that get put into linear. Devon is
already working on it. Dev's already got
PRs. So, it's very very helpful just to
get things moving. A lot of times, you
know, you got like the the molasses
around your your legs, you know, like I
just got to get moving before I start
get uh getting up to speed. And so, this
kind of helps with the ball moving a
lot. So certainly that's that's part of
the beginning of the day for
me and I think essentially what we found
right now is the morning time is check
out what agents did what they need to do
kick off the things that they need to do
and then come around I don't know around
lunchtime review everything you're going
to have a bunch of PRs you're going to
have your collateral maybe some emails
we got some email agents that do things
um and so that's one example big picture
I think every employee they can become a
lead manager type and and and I don't
mean necessarily a people manager but of
their AI agent counterparts that are
responsible for the jobs the person is
hired to do. I mean, we have content
marketing swarms that we use multiple
agents that that I'm orchestrating and
telling the agent, hey, the copy's over
here, optimize it, figure out the best
time for social posting. All this
happens and automatically schedules with
type fully we use. Um, so it's a it's
leveraging expertise of the human, but
with async workloads kind of just doing
it all so that when you get to it, it's
all ready to go. Now, back to my earlier
point, I think this leads to a much
flatter team structure and probably
different titles, honestly. Titles that
combine domain expertise with AI
know-how. I mean, we even have that in
our you said, Rick, that's not true.
It's always going to be the customer
support. Think so. It might be AI
engineer or AI um AI customer lead or
something like that. I mean even our own
industry it's AI engineer is now you
hear that everywhere and I think it's
going to be across the board across
everywhere in the organization. So that
leads us to the final point which is
rethinking the hiring process and who
you're hiring because when you start
thinking this way you start thinking not
just the hiring process and operation
but who you're hiring needs to be a
little different you know curiosity
adaptability those are things that are
in high demand right for creative people
for leadership roles so we know that but
essentially what we're saying is for an
agent native company that is required
hired. We have to have that right now in
order to hire somebody because they're
not going to be able to use AI uh the
way that we need them to. So, so maybe
another way to say it is AI fluency
becomes a mustave. You know, to
reference uh the old world, you would
never ever ever hire somebody in an
office job if they've never used a word
processor in their life, right? They
don't know how to use a keyboard. You
would never hire them. It's just
expected. You would even probably put it
on your job requirement. It's just
expected that they know how to use a
keyboard. Now, if you went 120 years
ago, that might be a debatable thing. I
don't know. Is it really needed? Do they
really need to use a keyboard? I don't
know. It's just typewriter. As long as
they have nice hand
penmanship. But AI fluency is actually a
really big deal for us. And I think it's
just going to keep being that way. It's
not really hard to imagine if the
expectation is a flatter or structure
where each employee is efficient at
directly guiding agents to task at hand
you and utilizing the person's expertise
through those agents, then you're going
to hone in on the ability to do that.
You're going to in your hiring process
want to find out if that person has that
ability to do that. It's just going to
be something that happens. I I think I
mean even in our current interviews
we're very very skeptical if someone
doesn't use AI and not familiar with it.
It's just immediate warning flags um now
maybe they haven't had the opportunity
to use it and stuff. Obviously, there's
there's scenarios because we're early on
in this that, you know, we have to be a
little understanding. Um, but it does
make us ask the question, does this
person have the ability to guide AI
agents and learn the little uh tips and
tricks and tweaks and and all that kind
of
stuff. And and even on a bigger picture,
you know, a reason a big reason why you
would hire a VP, for example, you bring
in a VP is for their network. you hire
them for their experience and the
quality of people that they would bring
in to fill out their team to do the job
that they need to do. So, in this new
type of company, the spotlight gets
really put on the like does this does
this guy know how to use agents? Does
this guy can he bring in people that
know how to use agents? Um, do they have
AI fluency? So, it comes a really big
important thing. And then if you kind of
just think through the the the life
cycle that okay let's say you hire that
person then the onboarding and then they
hire some other people to build out
their team. The onboarding is probably
different too right when you hire that
the intent of being agent native then uh
guess what agentic tools and systems
that need to be put in place for them to
be successful is really important. So
then it doesn't seem unreasonable to
attach an engineer to that team to make
sure that their agents are up and
running and build out. Um it's the same
thing with like new hires. You probably
would expect them the first few weeks to
solely be focused on getting their agent
set up to do their job. Makes sense,
right? In conclusion, just to wrap it
up, we're going through a profound
shift. We don't know exactly where we're
going to end up. You know, the ceiling
is being raised so high, we don't even
fully understand, I think, how large
this AI world and the economy will go. I
think it's a lot like the car industry.
We didn't realize how big the ceiling
was being lifted in the in the economy
when the car came along. And I think
that's the case with this this AI stuff.
So, I think AI agents will be deeply
embedded in every aspect of business.
And that means rethinking roles. It
means rethinking skills and I even think
it means rethinking culture and
operations. The move isn't merely just
businesses that use AI as a tool. That's
not what we're talking about. We're
talking about businesses that are built
around AI as a core primitive to their
existence. Again, from the driver
assisted to the AI automated uh driven
car. And that shift affords a ton of
opportunities. But it is a shift. It's
just going to create a lot of friction.
But I mean just just to tell you I just
with us we've been around for you know
15 16 weeks small team six seven people
and uh we built an entire Aenta cloud
infrastructure from scratch in just a
few weeks. That's unheard of. Like if
you asked me that a few years ago I said
there's no way. There's no way. But with
all of these tools and these agents,
these agents that we build ourselves for
our things and then uh Devon and some
others, man, we've made so much progress
on this. So, it's a huge shift and
especially for founders and tech
leaders, the challenge is that I think
fully embrace the paradigm shift. If
you're an experienced founder, this is
especially true, but it's especially
hard because you've got all this back uh
years and years and years of experience
and you might need to check some of that
experience at the door. Seriously, you
might need to rethink like you have all
this built-up experience that might no
longer be valid or only parts of it are
valid and you have it takes some
critical thinking to analyze that
because otherwise you just get stuck in
the old way of doing things. I mean PWC
of all of all places they they had a
really good report recently and one of
the comments they said was if you're
only using AI for a small efficiency
gain then you're falling behind because
there's companies that they're not just
using it for a small efficiency gain. So
my admonishment would be uh start from
first principles take this opportunity
to step back reimagine and refit your
company and your culture for this
future. you rewire the entire process so
that human to agent teams can scale that
impact
exponentially. I mean that might mean
again this is friction this is pain that
might mean redesigning your org chart.
It might mean redefining roles and
rethinking what skills you hire for.
It's a lot of change but it also can be
your unfair advantage if you do it. So
with that I'll just leave you with one
question. Is your company using AI or is
it ready to be built around AI? Thanks
for listening.